it's coming up december 26th to the 31st
we will be in texas missouri and ohio go
get your tickets end the year with us
co-headlining doing stand-up comedy it's
going to be fun it's going to be great
go to salvolcanocomedy.com or
christiecomedy.com is going to be great
and then also babe also babe you know
what i just put on sale today what's
that oh actually yesterday is i'm coming
to chicago i'm doing the chicago theater
use the pre-sale code chaos the pre-sale
is happening right now at christy
comedy.com the chicago theater march
12th baby okay and here we go for me i
gotta call out two dates san diego on
january 21st at the magnolia theater and
los angeles january 22nd at the wilton
theater i have not headlined in los
angeles yet it's gonna be a real special
show there's gonna be some surprise
guests there from the la area it's gonna
be a lot of fun go see that one last
thing to call out yeah we're both
playing the agora theater in cleveland
oh my god when are you going to be there
i'm going to be there on january 16th
babe yes and i'm going to be there in
march yes
so uh yeah so you'll be there
60 days after me i'm going to leave you
a joint underneath one of the seats i'm
going to tape it to one of these come to
ball shows at the igor theater if you
don't i'll kill your loved ones
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe
[Music]
don't care about the presents
underneath the hey babe tree
i don't need to hang my stocking there
upon the fireplace
santa claus will make me happy with the
toy on hey babe day
i just want you for my own more than you
could ever know
make my wish come true
baby all i want
[Music]
happy every celebration happy every
celebration happy happy kwanzaa god
bless it merry chris whatever you want
to do enjoy your holidays have fun fun
fun
uh in norway santa is gay now is that
right they've made santa gay in norway
um which is uh pretty cool um so yeah
got a big gay santa what do you mean
like he's just fully gay he makes out
with a guy on i mean just really he like
he came out christmas advert made by the
norwegian postal service uh show santa
claus uh in a gay relationship wow so
yeah mrs claus has been mrs claus has
has uh she's been written out of the
story
what can you do you know it happens i am
christmas to me
i enjoy christmas i do i really really
do but it stresses me out okay i get
really really really stressed
with christmas
this year
i wouldn't say i'm as stressed just
because
you know
in three days we're gonna we're gonna be
doing our shows together start in texas
december 26th
23rd today's 23rd so for three days for
now we'll be in we'll be in dallas so go
to christiecomedy.com or
salvanocomedy.com and get tickets you
see us we'll be in texas ohio and uh
texas missouri and ohio from the 26th to
the 31st so get the tickets uh making a
nice christmas gift come out with your
fam um
with the spurs whatever you want to do
remember what we promised saint lou st
louis you come out in the comments sorry
cincinnati if cincinnati sells out yes
we're going out with the crowd yes we're
going out with the crowd if it sells out
we're going out with the crowd so make
sure that sells out that's in babe
that's in eight days eight days um so i
feel like um i'm less stressed this time
let me just say something i'm sorry i'm
sorry to interrupt really
i usually just i'm a giver
but let's just say to cincinnati people
that in order to make this happen you
need to start talking to friends and
tell friends about it and bring friends
you need to spread the christmas cheer
and the word because we got to sell that
out it's not going to sell out on its
own it's going to take a christmas
miracle on the people of cincinnati to
come together to make a night that none
of us will ever forget i know all the
recent advertisements wherever you look
have been stopped to spread not
from the 26th or 31st we need you to
spread it we need you to go ahead and
spread it spread the word um so so um
it stresses me out because
i feel
i want my children great foot
i want my children to get gifts and i
i've already bought them their gifts and
i want you know
you know cross the list checking it
twice all that but
you know to where i have to go for
christmas eve in my my family's house i
love being there but i have to buy like
30 people gifts
and
i don't want any gifts like i don't care
buy my children i'll buy my kids gifts
i'll buy the kids gifts but why do i
have to buy
a 65 year old aunt anything i don't need
them to get me anything i know it's it's
do you get stressed by did you just say
it's giving joyous what do you say the
truth i'll tell you the truth for real
i love christmas i make no bones about
it it's my santa claus it's my favorite
holiday yeah i i i am and uh i love it i
actually i'm a person who keeps a file a
note file in my phone all year
if i hear something and i write it down
for people that i don't forget
um so
ashley's the opposite of my family
they're like hey why don't we all do a
chris kringle this way we don't have to
go crazy everyone get the kids and then
we all do a chris kringle so one adult
gets one adult and we're done and we're
done did it yeah and i get that i get
the convenience of that and i tell them
no problem and we do the kris kringle
and then i proceed to buy every single
person gift still
you do it anyway yeah i do it anyway
because it brings me joy so me agreeing
to buy one person is limiting my
christmas and i don't limit my christmas
let me ask you this today's december
23rd are you 100 done with your
christmas shopping yes and no like uh
you know i i have things in the mail
that i'm hoping still get here at the
cut off but then some people i won't see
until after we get back so you go big on
amazon
you know in in the last few years i have
gone big on amazon because it's really
the only practical way for me right you
know right now you're a good gift giver
i've heard but it has ever been a gift
uh that's what we've heard you heard
that i heard that on the street
uh is there a gift you ever gave that
you're like that was bad that went
really badly
i'm sure there's some with my girl i i
usually i usually like you know how they
say a guy can't don't you won't find
clothes or things like that you can't
get them because it's a very personal
thing to buy i usually hit it out of the
park with everything i get in the in
like all the time we've been together i
think i think i got two gifts that
looking back were like what was i
thinking one was like just a pair of
earrings that were terrible dude one of
those i don't really i'm not an earring
guy not a jewelry guy this wasn't
expensive hearing it was like an add-on
at the counter that i got they were like
terrible and then there was one other
thing but normally like i love just
being like get open it and then just
being like i [ __ ] nailed it like
that's what i'm about one of the
funniest things i've ever seen is one of
my boys and i remember we always go to
one of my friend's house usually on
december 26th after christmas like hang
out whatever get together one of my boys
came over once a few years ago and he
was like
just having he was so sad i'm like
what's going on he's like my girl dumped
me and we were like why
for christmas
their first christmas they were dating
for like eight months he gave her the
only gift he gave her was a card that
had a hundred dollars cash in it oh my
god and she got him oh my like
thoughtful embroidered shirts and
sweaters and this he gave her a card
with one hundred dollars who is this
person and how does he not know any
better she dumped him he's an idiot
did you what was your reaction to that
when he told you we were on the floor
dying laughing
i was like well you should just give me
this note yeah he was like he was like
but i don't understand like a hundred
dollars is like real money and i was
like not to your girlfriend it isn't oh
my god who gives a [ __ ]
you gave her cash cash yeah like he's
like he's donny brosco like he's
freaking donny brosk
a hundred dollars cash it's the most
thoughtless gift you could ever give is
there a more thoughtless gift than just
giving cat maybe
i know that cash is good and you know
especially now with the way the economy
is it's great to you know give people
cash but i want to know is cash the most
thoughtless gift is it just
what's worse cash or a gift card i think
if it's your partner or significant
other cash is a misplay but i think a
lot of times people would rather be like
just give me the [ __ ] cash because
you're gonna get me something that i'm
not gonna like or use i'm gonna have to
fake it i'm gonna either double gift it
throw it away try to return it and get
credit i think most people be like just
give me the cash but that really really
for me i get the logic but it takes away
the elements of christmas it does
i like it to be special i like the
challenge of finding a good gift and
receiving the joy i get in my heart when
they open up the gift that was a
thoughtful gift now do you wrap your
gifts by yourself
[Laughter]
well i'm not a great rapper
and i do as many
drop some bars yeah i do as many as i
can myself
and uh
my my my lady helps me and i'll tell you
how bad of a rapper i am i used to for
years for years i used to wrap gifts in
tin foil wow yeah because check it out
no scissors needed no tape needed
interesting shiny
and to be honest to give stay fresh stay
fresh why don't you give me a beat i'll
do a freestyle for you right now all
right
what's up it's chrissy claus coming at
you
at your balls gonna wrap up your gift in
tinfoil then i'm gonna ask my name
schmoyer i don't usually rap like this
but
uh uh
hold on
hold on we out here
yo
it's your boy chrissy kringle i'm gonna
come and give you some pringles i want
you to mingle but watch out you could
get covered
so
don't leave the stove it
on
for your mom
get a fake butt
hard to get a ticket hard to get a
ticket to funk master flex them
[Laughter]
could you imagine dude that would be i
mean what's more embarrassing
like if you went out there in front of
thousands of people and you were a
rapper and you had to freestyle rap and
you
like like a real eminem moment did you
see on that does that happen did you see
on the local news station the guy who
touted himself as a freestyle rapper who
wrote two or three free books about
freestyle rapping and live on the air
they go can you do a freestyle for us
right now and he goes sure sure and then
he goes
years ago they try to
can we see this can we pull this up what
do we have to google years ago they try
to put freestyle rap local news i'm sure
it'll come out freestyle he just gets
frozen on live air and he's like is this
live and she goes yeah and she goes
would you like to just is this the guy
yeah she goes would you like to just
read from the passage from the book
i can't wait to see this
can we show this we're going to find out
this is from the talk of alabama i don't
want to demand
uh that's an edited version she actually
says to him do you want to just read
from the book and he's like yes i'll
just read from the book
yeah
so how mutifying
because it's one thing to like bomb and
stand up but it's like it's comedy it's
funny but like when you're not supposed
to be funny at all yeah well we're
supposed to bomb i mean yeah it's like
it happened you had to try new [ __ ] i
used to go on the road with rappers and
i would watch a young rapper with no
shirt on with abs bomb bomb but how do
you run at a music show like explain
that it's way worse than comedy guys but
how though like you know what i'm sure
you're trying to freestyle
this is no this is even with oh you just
mean like like his regular material like
the crowds just like get out when music
bombs it's way more painful than comedy
because they also hate your vibe
wow yeah it's not good you almost can't
turn it around a song is like four
minutes
yeah it feels like yeah i was gonna say
like you can't we got our techniques you
know if something's not going well i
weave in weave out whatever it may be
yeah whatever it is interesting yeah
dude that was i mean yeah google that
because that was even painful just
watching that
i feel bad for that guy i'm sure he
commits suicide that night
right merry christmas
years ago they're trying to yo yo cause
you know i'll be reading the box
it was at the big suck was the instagram
um
speaking of the bible
did um
i brought i actually wanted to actually
show you this thing did you i've asked
you have you heard of dr the brand dr
bronner's no i never heard it it's a
very popular brand it's in most markets
right and it's very distinct because
they have this
very old-school looking label
on all their products
right
which i think by the way is a very smart
thing for companies to do in restaurants
if it's an old label or an old
storefront it tells me that it's been
around a while and then tells me
subconsciously it's good i swear to god
that must be what they're on to because
i saw this and i feel like it's good by
the way shout out dr broners i am
someone who uses your products now i've
used them for years different kinds not
old i don't always just get this
toothpaste but
recently i read the label because they
see how much writing is on the label
yeah do you see that's a lot of words
and i was like what is this
what does this say and let me read you
what it says
listen children eternal father eternal
one
for for on god's spaceship earth we've
with bomb
with bomb and gun we're all one or none
life's goal to keep my health to do my
work to love to live to see it i gain
and grow and give and give never to look
behind me for an hour never to wait in
weakness nor walk in power always
working
searching for more truth more light
always speaking fighting for what i
found good and right robbed starved
beaten fallen smeared and slandered wide
astray back with full truths i have
learned back to the way smile work help
build the brotherhood of man all man on
full truths all one god faith it can
stay so help us god hurrah ahoy and high
wow
now that's already a better freestyle
then
i mean i was i was brushing my teeth
when i caught this
i was just like there's a disconnect
here for me
that well i mean it's it's borderline
psychotic though i would imagine i mean
this guy has that those exact words
engraved with a kitchen knife somewhere
on his body
and then this is miss moore
wait there's more zor zeroster zorroster
the great asian teacher
asian teacher some six thousand years
back
he who sees god's soil with good seed by
loving toil
reaps greater merit wisdom progress
freedom happiness and health than he who
writes 180 books repeats 99 prayers or
sits 100 years in meditation exceptions
absolutely none
confucius israel moses jesus zoroaster
the type of hard-working men with whom
civilization begun
again this is an all-in-one peppermint
toothpaste i was gonna say this is just
toothpaste yes fluoride free 70 organic
ingredients but you know i i just i love
the products they're wonderful products
i love the packaging everything about it
i and i don't even this dislike i
actually think it's very curious and
peculiar that they put that on there but
what is that what is that what is going
on what's his name dr brianna broner
absolutely this is a this is a four in
one lavender organic sugar soap
absolute cleanliness is godliness teach
the moral abcs that unite all mankind
free instantly six billion strong and
we're all one listen children eternal
father eternally one
again this is a lavender soap
i just i'm a little confused i
understand i get there i get he's
preaching on maybe his uh philosophy i
love if you meet dr brown or too he's
not religious at all he's like bro
what's up yeah he's like he's like you
believe in jesus you freak you told me
dr broner yeah he's like come on dude i
do not have to sell toilet paper
[Laughter]
let me ask you a question did you buy
the toothpaste yeah you bought it didn't
you exactly
you're asking me like i'm stuck
you're washing your body with my
lavender scrub
well i mean listen they say the story of
christmas is that jesus today uh
december 25th is the day jesus was born
but when you look if you watch any of
those documentaries on the history
channel whatever they say if there were
shepherds out he wasn't born in december
because the shepherd wouldn't have come
out unless it was the spring
so unfortunately the truth of the
situation is that
december 20 there was a council called
the council of nicaea i think it was 3
45
a.d okay i think it was called the
council it was called the council and i
see i think it was 3 45 a.d or 336. they
picked a date they just picked they
literally did it you ready for this
sound babies don't tell me this don't
don't don't don't tell dr braun to this
i know
the the they picked they picked
christmas
they most likely picked easter and they
picked the four gospels matthew mark
luke and john because there was like 30
gospels so they just picked the ones
that look made jesus look the best and
then they picked december 25th
for i think it was because it was like
somebody's like birthday
no yeah and like that's what they did
but really he
we don't know jesus most likely we don't
know the date wasn't born this is
probably a springtime kid if there were
shepherds out yeah that's what they say
now well i mean
they did a good job because the branding
for christmas like with the snow yeah
imagine christmas in the sun i mean that
would suck no i was in uh
the florida keys one year on december
7th it was 95 degrees and people out
there all the houses lit up with lawn
decorations
and it felt like i was in another planet
it's it's very strange if you're if
you're if the temperature where you live
is above 60 degrees i'd say christmas is
cancelled in your city yeah that's what
i'll say so if you're listening right
now how do you watch christmas movies
and look out outside and you have to put
on spf yeah you know what i'm saying
by the way speaking of spf speaking of
christmas i'd like to shout out tom
brady
and the tampa bay bucks
for winning yet another super bowl
and
i'd also be remissed you might be remiss
if i didn't mention patrick mahomes yeah
it was a hell of a game
and i think we're going to see them
again next season both of them yeah and
uh you know brazil brady did it at 43 or
so you know what i feel like doing i
feel like doing it again i'd like to
shout out tom brady 100 percent of the
tampa bay bucks yeah just and and you'd
be even more remiss if you didn't
talk about patty muhammad why says them
chiefs yeah we double up because
it just feels there was a need to double
up the christmas spirit wants to do it
twice yeah
so still on track also uh do you want to
tell the audience about that last point
you left off on oh yes
yes oh the continuation right the big
continuation so the last point that i
left off
was the fifth the fifth um
the fifth thing that seneca said to live
by was death is not in the distant
future we are dying every day so merry
christmas yeah
i mean the first four if you watched
last week's episode and we know that
first we know that you did the first
four
were bangers yes and then that fifth one
was a real downer what are bangers in
mash
i don't know what is a banger i think
it's a saucy in the european i think
it's a bra and it's mashed potatoes it
got to be mashed potatoes pimpy
i think the banger oh there bang it
actually looks fantastic known as
sausages and mash is a traditional
british dish
um did you know that england and britain
is not the same thing
england's a part of brexit
you know like when you say britain when
you say i'm from if i said hey i'm from
britain what would you think i would
think you are
i would think that you are what country
am i from i would think you're from
england right but if you if i'm from
england i'm from england if i'm from
britain
i it's like i'm saying for i'm from
north america britain is encompassed by
northern ireland uk scotland in the uk
oh wait so britain is not the uk no i
think i think britain is i think britain
i'm not gonna look here's what i think
britain is okay
no britain is the uk here's what i think
britain uk england scotland northern
ireland and wales that's britain is that
britain
britain is the landmass where england is
england is one country in the united
kingdom it's four countries oh so which
one am i forgetting
united kingdom is a sovereign state made
of four countries england whales
scotland and northern ireland that's
okay so so where's britain is the land
mass
where england is
england is one country and the united
kingdom is four countries so britain is
england
it is english but it's the land
because the land mass where england is
where the landmass where britain is
encompasses england wales scotland
northern ireland have you ever been to
wales i have really i
want to go to wales like you can do you
see castles everywhere you go or just yo
i had a sick time in wales seriously i
went to castles and everything no i'm
being dead serious and i went out with a
nightlife i i went to leeds i've been
i've been there's leeds in wales no
i'm just saying i did a uk tour and i've
hit every [ __ ] up there
but whales do you anything significant
about whales because whales they say
i gotta go back and look at my notes
but i go on a tour of england
to you
that i really really wanted to or
england for all the uk people watching
and listening uh i see your messages and
i've never done it solo out there and i
promise you i will get out there i want
to go
i want to go too yeah i want to go bad
i love the uk it's a fun time out there
man they know they know how to do it
should we go together really really good
fans no joke really good fans yeah i
want to go with you and rent a bus
let's do it seriously i will do that
pimp will come let's do it all right
yeah i'm down here no joke down no joke
no pips never left the continental
united states i swear i was my first
flight was 26 25.
wow
the first time you what did what do you
remember that day the first time you got
on a plane yeah i prepared me to go do
something so what did you do but dude i
flew to south by southwest
[Laughter]
were you scared
like because you knew what could go
wrong i know i'm so old no i was just
pissed i i never went on vacation before
my first flight ever was a 1819
really never went on a childhood
vacation on a plane and then you saw
seinfeld right that's when that's the
same trip baby remember that right to
l.a
yeah i was on a flight when i was eight
i went to orlando shout out disney world
all right listen man i've been really uh
getting my mental health in check and
really been focusing and trying to calm
down and get in the right headspace and
i've been using the app headset space i
mean babe you know about this yeah i use
it on planes all the time it's seriously
it's like i can't calm myself down
like before we take off then use it
while we're in the air and i just
honestly man it's like my mind like
sometimes it feels like it's like
sprinting for years on end it just never
stops and it leaves trails of stress
anxiety fatigue and that just felt like
it was eroding my mental health
so and if you're nodding yes to this
it's time to adopt small daily practices
that will have an impact on your
long-term happiness and well-being and i
can confirm that this is true
and it's easier to learn with headspace
because however you're feeling try
headspace and listen it doesn't matter
even if you feel like you don't have
problems just go to headspace.com hey
babe and get one month free of their
entire mindfulness library and i
guarantee you even if you're feeling
great you're going to feel even better
if you do this i promise you yeah it's
actually kind of cool if you if you've
never tried one of these things before
do it and i think it's almost like you
can't not like it right because it works
and it just kind of literally calms you
down right and
if you don't have anything else that
does that kind of thing it's an app on
your phone you could do it anywhere on
the commute in the morning when you're
trying to rest at night that's what i
that's the most times i use it and this
is the best headspace offer available if
you go to headspace.com hey babe today
that is the best offer that they have
headspace dot com slash hey babe
all right listen guys if you're carrying
a credit card balance month after month
it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt with no end
in sight upstart can help you make that
final payment so you can get ahead
rather than looking at a credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com hey babe
that's
loan upstart.com will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information providing your loan
application that's upstart.com
i was supposed to go as a kid to disney
world and i got the flu but yeah you
couldn't go because your mom was getting
the fake news
yeah she was getting botox yeah hey you
got the flu could have been colvin could
have been that's you could have been one
of the early cases yeah that you got in
1977
six six very good bison ten buys you
were born in the bicentennial i was
you're a true american i have a
different quarter than everybody else
wow the back of my quarter is a special
bank yeah do you we're not going to make
it to 2076 probably well let's do the
math 21 minus 76 is 55. 55 added to my
age right now is 100 years old you could
make it why why couldn't i just know
that i was born
what did i do
i took the long route the scenic route i
was born in 1976 100 years later i it
would be 2076. you
you have an outside pimp almost
definitely will make it to the to the
tricentennial you think so because he
has because we're gonna make strides
pimp's going to make it pimp's going to
make strides
yeah cause cause yeah you might make it
buddy you might worry i'll uh upload you
guys to the metaverse
knock on wood i have good i i come from
pretty good genes my a lot of my
grandparents my grandma's still alive my
grandpa lived to almost 96 and
you know so so maybe i'll do it i don't
know knock on schmud speak christmas um
you don't have to talk about this in new
york uh they set the christmas tree on
fire outside the fox news i saw that
yeah yeah
but then they stay i mean that's funny
because i've walked past that christmas
tree i mean a million times yeah and
they laid it right on fire
yeah
folks
don't i don't
you know i'm gonna tell you something
whenever i've tried to light something
on fire it doesn't take
all right people do it i don't know dude
i'm sorry tell me give me a match at a
piece of paper i it won't get the paper
on fire i can't even like in the movies
they throw a match
ready for this i'll take it even one
step further i can't even light a match
or use a lighter every time i i go to do
a lighter i burn my thumb and i've never
been able not once in my life to take a
matchstick and light it isn't that wild
not once in my entire life lighting up
the fox chris this guy lit up the fox
christmas tree
lit it up in a different way
yeah yeah yeah i mean do you do
the lighter thing is that wild isn't
that weird
i know what you mean because it happens
every once in a while for me
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you just deal
with that well it doesn't happen often
every single time i do it i'm like do i
have it backwards yeah
do you think you i could never start a
fire in the woods forget it no you don't
see those people that used to take a
step into the flint or like two two
rocks or those two things they they get
a spark
no way dude never no way i'm telling you
right now if you gave me a match and i
tried to light this couch on fire i'm
telling you a book of matches i don't
know if i'd be able to do it you're
gonna be able to do it yeah don't try it
at home right
don't try it at home no liz how about
this ready for this we're gonna have to
play a little [ __ ] marry kill right now
oh
in the holiday spirit yeah ready to go
yeah
[ __ ] mayor kill
santa claus yeah
easter bunny um
who's the third one
let me get it
santa claus easter bunny whoever you say
is gonna be right because i blanked out
cupid
let's do cupid
no but who was your third one though
because it wasn't cubes i started the
let's play [ __ ] marry kill not knowing
where you're going not knowing where the
third one was going to be gonna pop into
me but it doesn't talk about i thought
about that episode
i thought your hair looks great i don't
have a leprechaun
by the way if you're not watching the
pot we love the listeners we love the
listeners yeah but if you are not
watching the pod for example i am
currently
fully dressed as santa claus yes and i
am currently in a uh ugly christmas
sweater with just santa claus hair off
yeah yeah so so so um i was gonna say a
leprechaun because it's ain't pat's but
then i was like no then i was like who's
the thanksgiving person there was none
and i was like who's the new year's
person sorry i landed a cupid now stupid
and a [ __ ] marry kill cupid
i guess you want to [ __ ] cupid right i
don't know do you want a [ __ ] do you
want to marry him
because he's the
whoa i mean the foundation right he's
love he's love so i think i i think i
marry cupid i'll tell you right now
i marry cupid
i i [ __ ] santa
he's jolly yeah this this and and and
he's giving yeah and uh i would [ __ ] him
and then uh the easter bunny i would
slaughter it
you could eat it yeah cause i'm not
gonna [ __ ] a bunny
no and then also let's be honest he's
just bringing chocolate to the table
nothing else nothing else nothing else
i mean same thing you could say for
cupid but at least cupid has a little
bit of an ammo beyond the chocolates
right i mean i know the easter bunny is
is the easter bunny related because it's
it's a separation of church and state
here right
like the easter bunny is has nothing to
do with it i brought it up with jesus uh
resurrecting nope the easter bunny is a
hormone
yes i would i would slaughter the easter
bunny i would slice his neck off you cut
him he cut his head clean off i would
cut his head clean off what can you yeah
yeah and i would leave it leave it
somewhere to
to warn people what you do when you just
10 people with sugar which is poison do
you know what you know what um you know
what um uh bunny is called in german the
when you when you eat rabbit haas and
pfeffer you know how i learned that from
the movie the mighty ducks from that guy
hans he says i have hearts and pepper oh
i saw i heard house of ever in the
cartoons let me ask you this
why are there eggs
tied to the to a bunny do bunnies lay
eggs
how does a rabbit get born
i think up through vaginal vaginal birth
that's what i thought right so where did
i think it's a vaginal bar where are the
eggs coming from
no bunnies do not lay eggs as placental
mammals rabbits develop embryos inside
of uterus and after pregnancy lasting
about 33 days
give birth to a litter of 12 bunnies wow
33 days that's a [ __ ] gestation
period that's a question holy god that's
a quick turnaround that's why people say
[ __ ] like rabbits
interesting because they just
procreate like a rapper out of nowhere
and then they give 12 bunnies are cute
where do the eggs come from
well there's chickens it's chicks are
chicks and chickens involved with
christmas money easter bunny with easter
are chickens involved with easter eggs
so why are we doing bunnies and eggs
uh
so they become a symbol of new life
symbol of new life this oh okay
rabbits usually give birth to a big
litter of babies called kittens that's
interesting so they became a symbol of
new life legend has that the easter
bunny lays decorates and hides eggs as
they are also a symbol of new life
that's why children wow enjoy easter egg
hunts
of [ __ ] yeah easter egg you're [ __ ]
that's why you're getting killed peter
cottontail
i mean just as in that sentence the
easter bunny lays
decorates
and hides the eggs that's what it is i
mean that is i mean that's a lot i mean
that's a lot too much it's gonna shoot
out an egg from itself
then paint it
and then hide it that's why nobody cares
about your holiday that's why santa's
getting [ __ ] and santa's gay so it's
right up our alley
now what animal would you replace easter
bunny with who do you think deserves it
gotta be a chick
a chickadee are you gonna do eggs you're
gonna do eggs do the chicken why why
didn't they do carrots
which by the way why do we do carrots
with bunnies because of drugs money
did he start that or was that already a
thing i think bonnie's vegetarians
too much right now
it's too much
rabbits don't naturally eat root
vegetables or fruit i love this is a
christmas episode we're talking fully
about easter
carrots and fruit are high in sugar and
should only be fed in small amounts as
occasional treats rabbits need mainly
hay and or grass some leafy greens and a
small measured amount of chelsea where's
the carrots coming from what can rabbits
i don't know i don't understand it i'll
tell you this i have not eaten a carrot
in maybe five years wait where were we
you mean even a cooked carrot as a side
i have not eaten a carrot and i want to
say five years easy that's wild cause
when's the lesson you've eaten the
carrots gotta be like a week ago
sliced carrots sliced carrots out yes
are you kidding me i ordered a carrot
sitter on the menu i'll tell you what
though unless i made a carrot like bugs
bunny maybe never i don't think i have a
full carrot like i've never skinned the
carrot and then chomped on it like it
was a treat like bugs bunny did never
who does that sound off in the comments
if you eat carrots the way bugs buddy
eats carrots i want to know who you are
leave your email because i want to talk
to you live on the next podcast as
you're eating a carrot bugs bunny style
exactly i've never even seen a bugs
bunny style carrot in my life in person
yeah what do you mean the carrot the
carrots the carrots what have you never
seen a carrot
i've seen only sliced carrots where do
you see a bugs bunny style carrot
everywhere
the markets have them
what do you mean the supermarket sells
them i've seen only babies
carrots
yeah
i don't think i've seen that
you're not looking at them it does not
seem like we see them i've seen bagged
carrots you do not do your own food
shopping i do well it just goes i've
been going there
oh they're there the carrots are there
yeah but i'll tell you what i haven't
seen not only myself i never seen
somebody just i've never been over
someone's house been walking in the
street we live in new york city yes
there's
seven eight million people i've never
seen someone just walking down the
street chomping on a carrot like bugs
bunny no but i would love to see more of
it
i would love to see it i wish one day is
national carrot day and that day
everyone you see is chomping on a carrot
like bugs that's what i want
for my new year's for 2022 i want to see
more people eating carrots bug bunny
style chocolate carrots chop up a carrot
raw chopped carrots i'll tell you
another thing
why do they call them bugs
i think
i don't know i think it was just a
cartoon because he's annoying
oh my god oh my god call 9-1-1
my body his internal body is imploding
you're kidding me did you just did you
just
make that leap yourself yeah just now
yeah oh
smartest people if that's real if
because he bugs everybody and that's why
i will literally
i don't know what i will i will eat a
carrot a day for the next year
oh yeah butcher box who's hungry baby
i love it what's my favorite thing about
butcher box you ask probably the fact
that i can get steak
lobsters shrimp whatever the hell i want
the food that they give me is freaking
fantastic okay the the animals are are
are fed uh properly taken care of
there's no antibiotics no no uh hormones
there's wild caught seafood um they have
beef grass-fed bees it's packed fresh uh
and shipped frozen for convenience i
save time on my next grocery trip it's
awesome well that's what that's the
thing i don't like going uh what
anything i can cut down to the
supermarket i like to do yeah you got to
start looking at meats and by the way
sometimes meats at the market are
suspect yeah the thing is i check
everything i want it it comes to me in
the mail every month i don't have to
even think about having the meats in the
freezer and it comes
in 8 to 14 pounds of beef in one shot so
you are stocked when you get it
no antibiotics no no added hormones
which is like that's another thing you
know you just kind of want it to be that
kind of farm to table feel babe yeah and
you ready for this this holiday butcher
box is giving new members one pack of
bacon for free
in every box plus 20 off each box for
the first five months of your membership
that's free bacon for life and up to 100
off if you go sign up at butcherbox.com
hey babe that's butcherbox.com hey babe
if you want free bacon for life yeah
that's a pretty good deal i mean what
else do you want yeah it's christmas
week and draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nba as a gift that will certainly put
you in the holiday spirit new customers
can bet just five dollars on any nba
team and win 150 in free bets if they're
victorious it's a great way to put some
extra jingle in your pocket if sports
book is available in your state your
christmas can still be merry everyone
can play for huge cash cash prizes with
draftkins daily fantasy basketball
contest draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars in total prices with the first
episode i've told you before uh
draftkings is an app on my phone i use
it every single week for me for football
and i'm not even a gambler but it just
makes my games really fun you can bet as
little as a dollar they also have free
pools to get into so it just makes
watching football on sunday a little
more fun for me so go get the draftking
sports book app now use the promo code
hey babe bet just five dollars on any
nba team and you can win 150
in free bets if they're victorious
that's promo code hey babe this
christmas week at giraffe king sports
book an official sports betting partner
of the nba must be 21 or older new
jersey indiana or pennsylvania only new
customers only minimum 5 deposit and a
one dollar wager required one per
customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler
why
but
oh animator bun bug's hard away
inadvertently christendom when his
casual sketch of a proposed rabbit
character was labeled bugs bunny by a
fellow employee but bugs
bugaboo what's bugger bear
oh yeah the word bug is actually short
for bug bear cr
pimp if that was real
it's such a good i say it is real good
thank you thank you i'll go with pimp's
definition of it
i cuz he does bug everybody i gotta be
honest i watched looney tunes my whole
life
bugs i could take them i'll leave them
elma fudd's my guy mine's daffy to be
honest i like that if you put them in
the real world those characters they're
queuing on
what so how so let's let's get into this
now they're domestic terrorists they're
crazy because they're they're destroying
everything constantly
they never help anyone on the show
i don't think i am blowing my mind today
let me let me explain something did you
ever see the one where bug bugs always
wins right right but daffy always loses
daffy is like the foil to bugs in a lot
of the episodes did you ever see the one
where they're in on stage in front of a
whole crowd like in a theater they're on
stage in a theater okay and bugs does a
routine and they're competing and then
bugs as a routine and the crowd goes
nuts and then daffy's like i've had
enough of this you always out do me you
always win and so for my
thing i'm going to literally kill myself
and he swallows gunpowder and a match
and he literally explodes on stage and
then his his angel
just goes up to heaven and the crowd
goes nuts and he beats bug's money by
committing suicide i swear to god and it
goes that's all folks that's all folks
and then kids are just sitting there
that's one i just realized right now
saying it out loud is one of it's one of
the most popular episodes and the
episode i remember the most but i'm
saying it out loud and i just for the
first time realized what actually went
down in this cartoon he fully committed
he was like you will not beat me they
will i will top you by killing myself
yeah can you can you can you type that
in
for children put um put daffy duck um uh
gunpowder
taffy duck suicide oh my god
it comes up the first thing that comes
up is daffy duck with a gun to his head
no no put that feet duck on fox yeah gun
powder
daffy duck uh gunpowder uh bugs bunny
put that see see what happens there
there it is here it is there it is
do it we won't be able to show this guys
here's what you do pause it put in
daffy's last trick
and then come back yeah okay and then
unpause i need to watch this now we're
gonna watch it we can't put this the
actual audio on because then we'll get
flagged and we'll get taken down i
thought i remembered his body with wings
going up in the sky i mean the fact that
he just said you've got to kill yourself
to win an oscar in this account it's
nuts so if you watch it and you came
back he he goes on stage in front of
this remember this is a this is kids are
watching this right this is a cartoon
it's looney tunes yeah he says i'll
drink a bottle of nitroglyceride
then another another chemical that i
never heard of something something 238
yeah uranium-238 uranium-238
nitroglycerin 19. he drinks it in a
bottle then he says a bunch of gunpowder
and then he says strike a match and
swallow the match and daffy is drinking
the poison on the stage then he explodes
and he says you must kill yourself in
order to win this award in this town and
then bugs claps and says that was
outstanding everyone loves you now
the if that came out today
it's basically telling people to kill
themselves well they said pimp pulled up
that that looney tunes and and these
cartoons were never meant for children
it says the warner cartoons were aimed
strictly for adults they were never
meant for children warner cartoons and
other animated short subjects were
screened for audiences of all ages at
movie houses before the feature
presentation but it was meant for
adults
well how do you keep that away from kids
i mean i guess it's i don't know but i
will tell you this nobody drank the
uranium and took the gunpowder nobody
killed themselves no i mean i watched
that i knew that i shouldn't so it's
like if i'm going to kill myself i'm not
drinking uranium and nitric oxide or
whatever and then lighting a match and
let myself blow up i'm not going to do
that right it's a big to-do no dude i'm
going to go on the bathtub and i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna bleed out oh i hate
that one i hate that one that's the one
i'm gonna do
that's what i'm gonna do merry christmas
that's gonna be my family's christmas
gift this year
[Laughter]
you guys are doing a suicide break now i
know this is hey babe
oh my lord yeah this has been the last
day baby
i just i'm just saying uh you know this
is this was some real real forward stuff
here yeah dark
forward stuff oh yeah well what can you
do you know i mean hey listen you know i
mean i feel like a lot of these cartoons
even roger rabbit you know roger rabbit
which came out in 1989 i was talking we
talked about that last week roger rabbit
i mean they have scenes where like one
of the guys is getting run over with a
[ __ ] forklift like they're supposed
to be a kids movie like these they do it
all the time they say the smurfs is for
adults all this stuff all this that's
the way you get out of it
they're like this is insane well it's
for adults for adults yeah yeah now
chris before we started you said someone
got thrown out of one of your
christmases oh my god i remember i must
have been eight or nine years old oh i
got a story yeah and one of my uncles
got
hammered was drinking vodka straight
from the bottle yeah straight from the
bottle i mean and was gone it was a sign
that's a sign right away was going the
little kids were opening up their gifts
he started opening up like our gifts
before we get to them back there it's
like you know like like just a drunk
idiot fellaini you remember i remember
every second first hand because it's
stuck with you and then my aunt threw
him out of christmas and i remember
my other uncle my grandfather and me as
an eight or nine year old boy had to
physically get my uncle out
into the middle of the street and i just
remember being like what am i gonna do
like this is a grown drunk man wow yeah
and i remember it being like crazy and
that day that was the last time he ever
ever in ever came to christmas and now
he's dead but that was the last time he
ever came to christmas
wow it's a christmas miracle the
christmas miracle so kids if you're
listening and we know that you are
just
throw your drunk uncle out he'll die a
little bit after that yes
so what's your story
oh we would talk about this earlier it's
not a christmas story but i don't know
well nothing about this episode it's
been about christmas anyway
except that we're dressed as santa why
did i why did i bring it up earlier when
before we started recording i brought up
you brought up ice skating a zoo a zoo
or animals something like you talked
about animals and i was like speaking of
animals what did i say about animals
because you just made that really uh
interesting trip with delilah
where did i go with delilah to the
circus oh that's right to the big apple
circus how was it the one of the best
shows i've ever been to in my life a
touring circus a touring it was it's
called the big apple circus i know i
know the brand you've been there well
ringling brothers and big apple big
apple was like the gobot to the to the
ringling brothers transformer got it you
know ringling brothers was wwe and and
then gobot or big apple apple was more
like aw but but that's not a slide on aw
aw wrestling right now is the best
product on the market and it's
unbelievable and i i watch it every week
i'm i love you guys i'm coming to a show
in jan this is our christmas episode
remember that
um um no but but it was always like a
little bit of a uh
a second fiddle but it was still awesome
but it just wasn't like it wasn't the
big big glisten glamour highly produced
so i haven't been to the um uh by the
way that somebody from the big apple
circus was a hay babe fan and gave me
and my kids uh free merch and free stuff
so thank you uh whoever that woman was i
really appreciate it they're elephants
there were no animals ah but that's the
new thing there were no animals we
always thought they were well taken care
of but then there was all those dogs and
[ __ ] that said no they're not but you
had the wandella family greg wandello
who's a world renowned tightrope walker
you had him tight real pork you had a
woman on the trapeze then the guy
who he was a little person the guy who
was running the show like he came out
with like you know welcome your next one
whatever all of a sudden just out of
nowhere
like two pieces of of paper like it
looked like toilet paper fall from this
fall from the top of the building he
gets on them and starts doing like a
flying no net trapeze act on the toilet
paper i was like i thought this guy was
just the mc whoa he's a little per takes
his shirt off he was jacked no
jack you'd have never seen it coming the
only one that was kind of a bomb was
there was like a dog trainer this lady
just came out with a bunch of dachshunds
and had them roll over even my kids were
like this one sucks i don't want to see
it i just i want to see at the circus
things i can't see i don't want to see
the docks in there yeah see at the
[ __ ] superman i got hammered there i
was drinking it was called um it was
sometime
lincoln center oh yeah so fun so fun and
then my kids my 11 year old stepson and
my daughter six-year-old daughter they
ate way too much candy and popcorn both
of them separately it just never
happened vomited at separate times about
30 minutes apart what active circus no
no on the way home in the car i had to
pull up pull over on the lower east side
so my daughter could throw up and then i
pulled over off the bqe in brooklyn so
my steps aren't because they just
ingested so much longer or circus
concessions yes and i told them yeah can
you google circus mishaps that might be
a fun little little yeah let's see
circus mishaps this is a good way and
speaking of circus mishaps i have a
story yes
circus gone wrong compilation every time
i see compilation i think of one thing
you say compilation is that wrong it's
compilation oh compilation yeah i'm
chrissy compilation
oh god this does not look good oh this
is a this is a fireball that is that
bugs bunny oh
when the when the motorcyclists are in
that ball that cage
they did not do this at the circus that
is insane they did not do this oh my god
who's the guy who's gonna effort
oh oh that could have been worse that
wasn't too bad how do they dismount now
see oh i saw this
you saw this not this but there was
somebody doing a flying trapeze act
thing
i mean that looks like cirque de soleil
type stuff though let the audio let the
audio audience know what you're oh my
god the whole crew oh my god that person
just let go 30 feet in the air and fly
into the stands when flying into the
stands and they're not okay
they called it fail force one which is
so i saw this trapeze they did this
without a net man
by the way you know have you done the
flying trapeze school in new york city i
haven't i always thought about oh
but there was a net there so it's like
who cares oh that one almost doesn't
count yeah
see i've never seen this uh
uh you gotta be i gotta be honest
uh
motocross bikes were not meant
to be driven inside of a circle
they just weren't
oh very mad max
it happened oh i saw this guy
this they had a person like this he's
going to fall i would imagine
this has to suck though
i mean do you understand how hard this
is
you know how many times he's gotten that
right and to get it wrong on the stage
live
my circus guy the one that uh did it
with me um he uh the only thing not was
a mishap but he gave up on a trick he
just said i can't do it really yeah he
was like very high up and he just said i
can't and then they and then everyone
you know the village came out like the
other works like clap it up clap it up
but we were all waiting we're like no
like you were just going up and like
we're all like that
what did he pray what did he bail on
what specifically similar to that to one
where he okay so what he does he kept
stacking things on things on things on
things and getting higher in iron iron
and the last thing he stacked he was
going to try to do a handstand on this
stack that like the bot the bottom of it
the first level was wheels so it was
like all moving it was like complete
core strength and all that and then he
kept trying to like he would get half
his body up into the handstand go back
reset that okay i think and i think it
was after like four or five attempts
they just shut down the music and he
just waved and then everyone's like yeah
clap it up and my daughter was like was
that the trick it was like yeah honey
all right i'll i'll i'll i'll tell you
one quick thing because it's very
apropos so i was up at like i think it
was like lake george or upstate or
something i was there for a few day trip
with a family and there was we were on
like a campsite or something like that i
don't know but there was a main
entertainment area where they had a show
every day at like noon okay and in the
show it was a variety act and people
came out and did magic people came out
and did certain acts i believe there was
a host and um i was there for three days
and i went every day so i saw the same
show all three days and i remember this
cowboy came out and he was like hey this
was his joke he's like hey my name's bud
and they're like hey bud and he's like
bud wiser
and i
laughed yes right and so then the next
day when he came out he goes hey my name
is bud i'm like i saw this yesterday i
was that guy yeah i was that kid
oh no i said it after i go will tomorrow
be different or something so the next
day he comes out he goes my name's mick
michelobe
right yeah all right anyway i watch all
the acts and then there's this act and
it's this guy in a sequence glittery
cowboy outfit with ice skates and they
wheel out this sheet of ice onto the
stage and it's probably as big as this
room only right and the guy comes out
with a chimp the chimp is a chimpanzee a
chimpanzee or yeah chimp 100 chimpanzee
and the chimp is also in a sequence
cowboy outfit with the hat on they're in
matching cowboy heavens and he's doing
this stick with the chimp he's like oh
take that and he's doing this little
back and forth by the champion
and like they have an act a routine they
do and they did it every day and it's
silly but it's fun it's good for kids
and uh the chimps on it and they have
these it's almost like when an act comes
out and does like uh one of these things
you know the
ventriloquist triloquis yeah so they
have this thing down and the chimp
students and then at the end they skate
they ice skate together the chimp has
skates on they're both in leotard
sequence cowboy have hats and they both
have on ice skates and they start
skating together
and doing like skating backwards getting
the circles to hold each other's hands
and they go round and round in a circle
right off the stage it was set up like
cocktail tables like it was almost like
it was like little cocktail tables of
people at cocktail tables and we were
right against the stage and
the third day the chimpanzee was being a
little bit uh feisty unagreeable feisty
randy whatever you want to call it and
it was no see this is like
so
the chimp was already misbehaving and he
like in within the act he was like
trying to correct the chimp right and
then they start to do
the skating and they're holding hands
and they're twirling and they're
twirling and twirling and it just looked
like
there wasn't any
uh
it didn't look like they had control and
then at the edge of the at the edge of
the stage were these bulbs you ever see
like in a makeup mirror in a dressing
room there's all those bulbs yeah this
lined the edge of the stage the bulbs
and they were all lit up and the ice was
behind that and then
they were they were going going and all
of a sudden they go in a circle and the
chimp
the chimp lets go of the guy's hands and
he shoots forward
shoots through the lights the lights pop
and he launches off the stage
in full sequence cowboy outfit
in the in the ice skates in midair and
just slams down on the cocktail table in
the front of a lady
two ladies right he's he goes flying
into it the whole cocktail table goes
over he lands on a lady she flips over
they're on the floor and then she goes
the chimp bit me the chip just bit me
and she gets up and she had on like a
skirt a big meaty thought was exposed
and there was bite marks and like red
blood blood rocks
and the gut and the chip was going nuts
the chip didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on and the guy was like i was so
nervous and he just jumped over the
stage he got the chimp and then the
chimp he took the ship back on stage and
the lady was going he bit me baby
thank you very much everyone thank you
so much ladies and gentlemen and he just
like he was he was beat red and sweating
and him in the chimp left the stage oh
my god dude that woman has aids i know i
know and and and immediately after that
uh
like the owner the security run out and
they lift up a leg and she's like i'll
tell you why right now
this has been hey babe
merry christmas
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey